[Música]
[Aplausos]
existem segundos que podem mudar para
sempre as nossas vidas pela capacidade
de fazer urgente romper com o passado
que a gente não quer é criar um futuro
que a gente quer
eu costumo jamais e segundos de vértices
de ruptura na minha vida um segundo
desse aconteceu faz um tempão no dia 11
de maio de 1998 às 23 horas e 17 minutos
aí me pergunta para maurício já faz
muito tempo como você lembra disso
é uma boa pergunta por que provavelmente
ninguém aqui lembra do que fazer nesse
dia e horário certo mas eu me lembro com
o incrível nível de detalhes sabe onde
eu tava e como tinha chegado lá a gente
pode imaginar talvez você tivesse lá nos
primeiros momentos do seu sono
talvez você tivesse assistindo televisão
talvez você já tivessem sono profundo
mas eu eu me encontrava numa situação
bem inusitada
naquele momento eu estava dentro de um
túnel escuro completamente submerso na
água sem poder respirar sem enxergar um
palmo à frente do meu nariz
como é que eu cheguei ali vão para
explicar isso eu vou convidar vocês a
votarem um pouquinho no tempo comigo
pode ser beleza
no dia anterior um pouco depois das 11
horas da manhã eu ea minha equipe de
exploração entramos em uma das maiores
cavernas do brasil localizada no sul do
estado de são paulo a gente queria
visitar uma das galerias mais bonitas de
formações rochosas que existe em todo o
mundo a nossa equipe não era grande não
cinco pessoas quatro homens e uma mulher
o mais experiente de todos um amigalhaço
meu carlão cara sabe amigo do peito
o calor era o mais experiente um geólogo
conhecia tudo de caverna já tinha
visitado caverna no mundo inteiro eu
júnior ricardo a gente tinha uma
experiência média que a gente adquiriu
ao longo de seis anos praticando esse
esporte aventura espeleologia o nome
estranho mas é isso mesmo espeleologia
exploração de cavernas ea única mulher
da equipe adriana
ela era um pouco inexperiente tá vou
falar real era a primeira vez que ela
entrava numa caverna
ela nunca tinha estado numa caverna e
ela só estava no grupo por dois motivos
o primeiro é que ela era namorada do
ricardo e por isso ele queria que ela
tivesse lá ele queria muito que ela
tivesse lá e havia um outro motivo
ela era a única que tinha carro
a gente também queria que ela estivesse
lá por isso né
a decisão de entrar naquela caverna fez
com que nós cumprimos todas as regras
todas as normas porque porque a gente
precisava de uma autorização ea gente
não tinha então a gente resolveu entrar
sem autorização
aquela caverna tinha uma grade e essa
grade tinha um cadeado mas isso não era
problema porque a gente tinha uma chave
tudo bem que essa chave foi feita pelo
carlão de forma ilegal quando ele
trabalhou como voluntário do parque
tranqüilo ea decisão de entrar ali
contrariando as normas faria com que a
vivência nas próximas 48 horas situações
que eu jamais havia imaginado no exato
momento em que eu entrei ali e deixei
para trás a luz do sol eu tomaria uma
das decisões mais impactantes para o meu
futuro e que horas mais tarde se
transformaria por completo a minha vida
é claro que não fazia a menor idéia
disso tá como a gente nunca imagina que
o segundo que vai mudar tudo pode ser
sei lá agora por exemplo vou propor um
rápido exercício pra vocês
nós sentimos um segundo vocês tocam
fazer seis vezes comigo sim então ok eu
vou contar até três quando eu contar a
gente sente o segundo vamos lá 1 235
segundo passou
se você sentiu é teu se você perdeu ele
nunca mais vai se repetir a cada segundo
é único mágico especial nas nossas vidas
nós levamos as que mais ou menos umas
duas horas para chegar lá
aquele é um dos lugares mais bonitos e
frágeis que eu já estive em toda a minha
vida estalactites se desenvolvem na
proporção de 1 milímetro cada três anos
cara você olha para essa arte de 11
metros e fala caramba isso aqui tem três
mil anos e é no gotejar da ponta da
tabela tite que acontece a precipitação
da qual cita que vai depositando ali o
calcário e formando aquilo
uma verdadeira obra prima da natureza
criada pela paciência
o que a gente não imaginava é que a
paciência da natureza e iria se
contrasta nas próximas horas com
desespero de tudo que a gente tava pra
viver ali é que o caminho de volta era
bem difícil enquanto caminho de ida era
intuitivo e linear você olhar e falar
ver por aqui o caminho de volta começou
a apresentar tantas opções mas tantas
opções a gente não sabe muito bem qual
pegar a gente acabou pegando assim
aleatoriamente e nós escolhemos caminhos
errados que nos levaram a pontos mais
profundos e desconhecidos daquela
caverna em pouco tempo a gente já estava
a quilômetros de distância da luz do sol
que lembrem lá fora ninguém sabe onde a
gente estava e pisando em áreas que
nenhum de nós jamais havia pisado gente
no começo está perdido é muito massa
curti muito tapetes não faz idéia eu
nunca tinha estado perdido era uma
alegria flick legal tô perdido
só que com o passar do tempo
aquela euforia foi dando lugar para o
medo e para desespero
a gente chegou à conclusão de que havia
poucos recursos por exemplo a gente
tinha poucas pilhas para abastecer as
lanternas e isso era desesperador
eu particularmente perceber que a gente
tinha pouca comida isso pra mim era mais
desesperadora ainda então nós pensamos a
gente tem que arrumar um jeito de sair
logo daqui vamos pensar numa estratégia
a caverna é o menor montanha e na base
dela tem um rio que atravessa por
completo o rio atravessa montanha e vem
para a superfície pela boca da caverna o
que nós pensamos se nós chegarmos no rio
é só seguir a água como a água sai na
boca da caverna seguindo a gente sai lá
também
e como a gente estava numa parte
superior a estratégia de sempre porque
de sendo sempre a gente encontrar o rio
esse é o caminho mas a infinidade de
caminhos começou a se misturar com uma
infinidade de túneis sem saída eu me
lembro bem que a gente andava há 10 15
20 minutos e de repente encontravam tudo
sem saída e tinha que voltar pelo mesmo
caminho
às vezes acontecer algo pior a gente
andava uma hora ou uma hora e vinte de
repente falava cara não é possível tenho
certeza que a gente já
estou aqui olha aqui e aí a gente estava
andando em círculos e essa rotina foi se
repetindo uma hora duas 35
essa rotina se repetiu por 32 horas
eu disse 32 horas
você consegue imaginar o que são 32 hora
32 horas caminhando 32 horas voltando
para o mesmo lugar 32 horas andando em
círculos e a cada tentativa frustrada
era como se aquela caverna levasse um
pouquinho da nossa esperança embora
e foi exatamente quando a esperança
estava quase terminando que aconteceu
algo muito bom a gente começou ouvir um
barulho de água e alguns minutos depois
ali na frente estava o rio
eu pensei é só entrar nessa água seguiu
seu fluxo ea gente vai sair na boca da
caverna e se esse caminho pode levar de
volta para a superfície e pode me levar
de volta para minha própria vida
só que entrar naquela água não é pra
qualquer um
existe uma boa dose de coragem água
muito gelada e não é só isso
quando você entra naquela água é como se
você disparasse tipo uma bomba-relógio
saca porque você vai ter pouco tempo
para sair de lá
sob o risco de entrar num processo de
poder mia a perda do calor corporal cuja
consequência pode ser a morte todos nós
ali tínhamos consciência disso mas a
gente também pensava que aquela era a
nossa melhor chance de sobrevivência
e foi assim que nós desejamos entrar no
rio
eu nunca vou esquecer nunca a sensação
que entrar naquela água é como você
assim como se você tivesse várias
lâminas sabe perfurando o seu corpo ao
mesmo tempo porque o frio gerador
isso me ensinou que é possível sentir
dor e alegria ao mesmo tempo
se por um lado aquele frio era quase
insuportável por outra via a consciência
de que era só seguir naquele rio e logo
logo nós estaremos na boca da caverna
bastava ter foco determinação
persistência mas a parte mais difícil
de tudo que a gente tinha pra viver ali
estava só começando
eu comecei a perceber isso à medida em
que eu andava no rio e olhava pro teto
aquele teto que no começo era alto e ele
começou a ficar mais baixo mais baixo no
princípio pensei assim acho que algum
tipo de ilusão de ótica não deve está
acontecendo isso não mas logo à frente
não haja mais dúvidas o teto baixava
tanto que encostava no espelho d'água ea
água continuava o seu fluxo normal
encostada ali no teto do túnel
se nós quisermos continuar naquele rio
nós temos que mergulhar naquele túnel
sabendo que não havia ar para respirar
não era possível acender lanternas
lembre se que em 1998 ea gente não tinha
grana pra comprar uma lanterna que a
sentença embaixo d'água
a gente não sabe o tamanho daquele tony
voltar para a área seca agora para
pensar o macacão molhado naquele
ambiente frio voltar pra área seca
poderia significar dezenas e dezenas de
horas em busca de um novo caminho
e aí o nosso destino estaria traçado uma
enorme chance de morte por hipotermia
não havia outra alternativa senão entrar
naquele túnel torcendo que ele não fosse
cumprido
torcendo que ele fosse curta o
suficiente pra que a gente do outro lado
ainda tivesse um pouco de ar nos pulmões
e foi assim que um a um todos resolveram
entrar naquele túnel
eu fui o último porque eu não queria
deixar ninguém para trás e foi então que
aconteceu o maior verdes de ruptura de
toda a minha vida
exatamente às 23 horas e 17 minutos o
dia 11 de maio de 1998
eu esperei todo o ar que cabe nos meus
pulmões
então resolvi mergulhar naquele túnel
quando coloquei a cabeça ali eu me
lembro que a primeira coisa que eu
perceber um silêncio um silêncio
aterrorizador como se eu tivesse
migrando para um outro mundo mais
gradativamente aquele silêncio foi
virando o barulho de um turbilhão de
água e eu não consegui nunca consegui
abrir
os olhos embaixo d'água já não consigo
fazer isso até hoje
mas ali também não é fazer a menor
diferença porque as lanternas não se
acendiam eu ia me movimentando no de uma
maneira que era um misto entre caminhar
nadar mas sempre sempre
tateando o teto na expectativa de que a
qualquer momento
aquele túnel acabasse mas o tempo ia
passando a cada novo centímetro a cada
novo passo a cada novo metro
eu me convencer de que talvez aquele
túnel não tivesse fim adrenalina subiu
coração bateu mais rápido mais consumo
de oxigênio e definitivamente não sei
explicar porque o meu corpo inspirou
todo a vocês podem fazer comigo por
favor expira em todo o ar dos pulmões
fiquem assim eu estava assim
completamente submerso num túnel no
escuro sem poder respirar agora
agora pode esperar para não morrer
tranquilo que eu vou narrar agora é
levar alguns minutos mas ali durou
apenas um segundo em apenas um segundo
eu me dei conta de que talvez o dia
seguinte já mais existir se sabe eu
comecei a pensar
acho que o dia de amanhã não vai chegar
não enfrente a percepção da finitude da
minha vida os meus valores se inverteram
por completo em apenas um segundo
eu percebi que tudo aquilo que eu sempre
dei valor na verdade não tinha a menor
importância e as coisas às quais eu
nunca tinha prestado atenção
de repente se tornaram as coisas mais
importantes que eu podia ter
aliás ter essa é uma palavra
interessante o que é teu de verdade o
que te pertence
ali eu percebi que eu nunca tive nada o
que eu chamava de meu meu tênis
minha roupa meu computador nada era meu
porque não podia levar comigo
as únicas coisas que eu tinha era os
momentos que é vivido com as pessoas e
acredita em mim
mesmo assim eu tinha estragado muitos
desses momentos tinha jogado muitos
deles fora eu ali percebi que nós
os conflitos com as pessoas que nós
amamos por motivos fúteis
brigamos com as pessoas por motivos que
não vão fazer a menor diferença
no último dia das nossas vidas quando
cada um de nós estiver dentro do nosso
próprio túnel escuro enfrentará nosso
último dia de passagem aqui na terra
outra palavra preocupação o que preocupa
o que faz você perder o sono
eu tinha tantas preocupações ter grana
ter um bom estatuto social de roupa de
marca batalhar para ter o carro do ano
nada disso tem importância mas pra mim
mas em compensação como eu queria uma
oportunidade de almoçar mais uma vez com
os meus pais eu me lembrei não esqueça
disso uma lembrança que veio na minha
cabeça quantas vezes eu saí com um prato
de macarrão do colo na companhia dos
meus pais para na companhia da televisão
deixando eles ali sozinho e tudo que eu
queria agora era só mais um almoço em
família
aquele segundo também impulsionou na
direção dos meus maiores sonhos porque
eu percebi que até então eu vi a vida
passar sabe como a gente assiste a um
filme no cinema você vai comprar um
refrigerante pipoca senta naquela
poltrona confortável e ver tudo passando
mas às vezes se emociona curte mas você
não consegue influenciar no roteiro da
história
eu prometi que se eu saísse daquela
situação eu iria tomar as rédeas da
minha vida e ir em busca dos meus sonhos
das minhas maiores conquistas e foi
frente a essa improvável inversão de
valores que a minha mão tocou uma bolha
de ar e eu pensei
graças a deus eu posso respirar mais uma
vez e quando eu coloquei a cabeça ali
naquela bolha de ar aquilo não era uma
bolha de ar no aquilo era o outro lado e
havia quatro pessoas felizes porque a
quinta havia chegado eles me puxaram com
tanta força que meus braços saíram
arranhados eles me abraçaram tão forte
que eu quase morri sem ar no meio deles
mas vocês já ouviram um ditado que diz
que desgraça pouca é bobagem pois é o
nosso alívio durou pouco tempo
a caverna tinha preparado mais uma
oportunidade para a gente refletir sobre
as nossas vidas
as pilhas lanternas se acabaram antes de
agir
chegar na saída e caminhar naquele rio
escuro era era impossível não dava
do lado direito havia uma prainha que já
estava nos acompanhando algum tempo eu
sabia que aquela era uma área que de vez
em quando poderia ter algum tipo de
turista lá então nós pensamos nós temos
que ficar aqui torcendo por aqui alguém
passasse lá e nos resgatasse e foi
naquela praia que nos sentamos ali nós
encostamos os corpos para trocar calor
ali eu mergulhei nos meus mais profundos
pensamentos
foi ali tremendo de frio nas próximas
horas que eu pude perceber que além
daquela cavar caverna enorme física onde
eu estava
existe uma outra caverna aqui dentro de
mim eu jamais tinha visitado esta
caverna e que essa caverna interna
poderia me revelar uma nova forma de ver
a vida um novo jeito de dar os próximos
passos caso eles realmente acontecer sem
por sorte esses espaços começaram a se
tornar reais enquanto o sol nasceu
naquela terça feira os nossos olhos com
as pupilas dilatadas pela escuridão
perceberam o quanto nós já estávamos
próximos da saída
bastava ficar em pé e caminhar naquela
direção
nós demos os braços e lá nós fomos e
depois de 44 horas longe da luz
nós saímos pela mesma boca de caverna
que nós havíamos entrado e eu prometi
para mim mesmo que aquela experiência
iria me conduzir para o futuro que eu
queria construir hoje quase 19 anos
depois
cada integrante da nossa equipe seguiu
sua própria história
eu eu eu resolvi compartilhar com todos
vocês essa experiência mas não só essa
experiência principalmente uma das
lições mais importantes que aquelas 44
horas ensinaram cada ser humano tem uma
caverna dentro de si ea gente precisa se
perder aqui dentro pra perceber que a
vida é uma grande oportunidade de usar
eu aprendi que cada segundo é um vértice
de ruptura uma oportunidade para entrar
nessa casa interna uma oportunidade de
tomar decisões certas ou erradas
elas vão nos dar força elas vão mostrar
é possível encontrar saída na verdade só
vai ser possível se a gente ficar parado
pra sempre no mesmo lugar
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]